normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government so we
do have another massive breaking story
in fact it is so breaking it is a
Twitter thread that has not yet been
written up but this is the censorship
industrial complex report being released
by The GOP rep Jim Jordan says bomb
shall report hundreds of secret reports
show how DHS cisa the gec state
department in Stanford and others worked
together to censor Americans before the
2020 election including true information
jokes and opinions the federal
government disinformation experts at
universities big Tech and others and
others work together through the
election Integrity partnership to
Monitor and censor American speech let
me just pause right there I'll give you
a personal example that election
Integrity project or whatever it's
called claimed that I Tim pool was one
of the largest spreaders super spreaders
of election misinformation you're a
super spreader now here's the thing that
actually was shocking to me because I
have since the election maintained Trump
lost to Joe Biden MH often saying that
the issue was ballot harvesting and
things that they they put out the Time
magazine article so why would they claim
I was spreading misinformation when
you've got it's because they want to
attack influence right and so long as I
was reporting on say Texas V
Pennsylvania or instances that needed to
be adjudicated it wasn't that I was
spreading misinformation all of my
sources News Guard certified it was that
they could not allow there to be a
narrative that there were questions that
needed to be answered by courts so they
lie claim I spread misinformation don't
say what misinformation that is
therefore it makes it impossible to sue
them and when the media reports it you
can't sue the media for for reporting
what a university said but let's read
more Jim Jordan says according to one
EIP member it was created at the request
of sisa the head of the EIP also stated
that EIP was was created after working
on some monitoring ideas with sisa EIP
stakeholders including the federal
government would submit misinformation
reports the e IP would analyze the
report and find similar content across
platforms it would then submit the
report to Big Tech often with a
recommendation on how to censor ladies
and gentlemen what we are seeing what we
have long speculated and and gotten
various reports hinting at or confirming
portions of is now the overt and direct
GOP government Congressional
confirmation the US government
intelligence agencies were using third
parties through universities to censor
people who supported Donald
Trump yeah the word stakeholders too
which just immediately makes me think of
CLA Schwab who's like the future isn't
stockholders it's stakeholders it's like
the whole great reset narrative is just
either intentionally or accidentally
seeping in even the writing where do
they use stakeholder in reference to
what the great reset he like the future
the the industrial fourth Revolution is
when he quoted it he quoted it in then
the thread somewhere where he said the
word stakeholders something like
stakeholders they targeted politicians
Marjorie Taylor green Governor Mike Huck
there yeah uh Candace Owens Jack soic
Charlie Kirk Benny Johnson Tom fitten
not on these lists I know you know they
they put it in my Wikipedia page that
I'm a super spreader based on the EAP
and Jim Jordan didn't even give me an
honorable mention come on Jim we got to
bring him on the
show pay for this no they also say uh
Michelle Malin Dave rubben James O'Keefe
it's absolutely absolutely insane but
who isn't on the list is even more
telling right here's some examples
here's one it's a a tweet from G saying
Pennsyvania Democrats are method method
uh meth method methodologically method
methodic methodically why can't I say
that word changing the rules cuz I want
to say methodologically but then I keep
going back to comp methodically changing
the rules so they can steal an election
it is amazing open to honest ruthless
and will I can't read what it says
unless the state is flooded with law
that was before the election too so he's
not even making a false claim about how
the who won the election he opinion it's
an
opinion I mean that's the thing though
they will pick all kinds of people that
they don't want talking at at the same
time here's a joke they removed no no
comedy either you know he said my H said
stood in the rain for an hour to early
vote today when I got home I filled in
my stack of mail and bouts and then
voted the ballots of my deceased parents
and grandparents they vote just like me
he's making a joke that's absolutely
amazing no he really did that who did we
miss did you have a social media post
that was targeted by the EIP it's clear
why Stanford tried uh tried only
produced these after the Judiciary GOP
and weaponization threatened contempt um
yes I will absolutely be reaching out to
my Representatives about um how I can
assist for if there is any action being
taken based on the people who are named
uh I absolutely will throw my name in
let's get Jim Jordan on the show
Cassandra make it happen I love that guy
personally and I think this is very
preent absolutely but also what happens
that's my thing like I I think this is
great information come out and then and
then what that's what I worry about with
all of these we had an investigation we
uncovered this stuff anyways now that
we've told you that's the end of it well
now what you do is you build censorship
resistant systems protocols things like
Noster noer however you want to
pronounce it um I was actually did an
interview with Bill opman today CEO and
founder of Minds talking about
censorship resistance and things like
that Brier Mesh networking things things
that can't be censor you can you can
always censor them locally like you can
Blacklist them from appearing on your
part of the of the network but you can't
make it go away well the crazy thing too
is just like we were talking about
earlier a lot of the stuff that's coming
out now is stuff that was already
publicly known like if you did a little
bit of research years ago you could find
details about the hunter Biden laptop
what was on it there's Biden laptop
email.com where you can search based on
keyword and find stuff like the public
was able to access the information that
while Joe Biden was vice president $23.7
million went to metabiota and Rosemont
senica Partners was invested metabiota
so those returns would have gone back to
Joe Biden's pocket and so that
information information is always
already been public four years and now
we're just seeing these committees just
admit that it's real admit that the
laptop's real admit that this evidence
is real I think that it's it's just
telling how screwed up our system is
when it's not about whether or not
people have access to the truth but it's
about who admits the truth is true in
March of 2021 EIP put out a a report
that that uh a report by uh the guardian
reported on it saying 15 of the top 25
21 offenders were verified including
Eric Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump Jr
James O'Keefe Tim P Elijah Riot and
Sydney Powell all 21 of the top accounts
for misinformation leaned rightwing the
study showed uh I uh never put up
misinformation and that's why and
everyone knows this all of my sources
always are certified by newsguard I
think newsguard is biased I think they
have they they have posted incredibly
wrong information about Tim cast.com
they've they did this dirty trick where
they claimed that they emailed us and
because we didn't respond they
downgraded us again even though no we
checked they didn't how are you
rightwing though I don't think of you as
like a right Wier well it's it's lies
but here's my point if I'm going to use
their standard for what's true and they
call me misinformation that's exactly
the point so there was um a really
interesting story pertaining to co and
lab leak where they wrote I think they
wrote it in our uh uh uh newsguard wrote
it in our report or someone else's I
could be I can't remember which one and
they said that this is in yeah I think
it was ours they said said it is
incorrect the uh something about like
Ukraine Labs or something like that it's
not true this was never revealed and
then I showed them the New York Post in
the Daily Mail News Guard certified
sources confirming what they claimed was
false I said now hold on you say this
story about coid lab leak is false but
you certified Daily Mail and the New
York Post as factual and they claim both
of these that it's true so who do I
trust the random employee telling me I'm
wrong or your own certified news sources
and they were like oops
if Stanford is going to come out and
accuse me of wrongdoing despite that it
shows you that it's political it is fake
and they are simply trying to steal an
election yeah I mean not for have the
student loan crisis but all universities
are basically dependent on federal
funding and so that means that they are
uh they they are in arm of the federal
government to a certain extent they want
to make the federal government happy and
so they'll play ball with them and
whatever way possible I mean the
relationship is obvious and yet we
pretended like this wasn't going to
happen I don't know I don't get
it I mean what what did you say about
the student loan crisis that they
they're buying people off by paying if
you're a college right and you know that
you can charge whatever you want as long
as you make the person take out student
loans which are guaranteed by the
federal government because you can't
declare bankruptcy on them and they will
give them to whoever they think needs
them oh then
youal money under this idea of like oh
we're bringing in students but not to
mention the direct funding that they
just give too so you're ineligible for
your funding as a university if you
don't enforce Title 9 regulations which
don't allow the the defendant to face
his victim if he's accused of sexual
assault on campus and things like that
so you see these kids getting kicked out
of college and stuff for false
accusations of sexual assault it's not
even a criminal court it's just a
College Court that has to do what Title
9 says otherwise they not eligible for
federal funding for their for the
University so you see a lot of
atrocities happen on college campuses
related to the fact that they're so
vulnerable and so dependent on the
federal government's funding I think we
have the same problem at the state level
like we wouldn't see a civil war from a
state unless things got way more extrem
than they even got in 1862 in my opinion
because all the states are so
financially dependent on federal aid for
things like roads and infrastructure
it's like they give us so much money we
would never rebel against them because
all of a sudden that's cut off at a
state level it have to be the people
that would stand up not it's never going
to be a state government you know I have
to wonder with the with this the release
of this report coming from official
government sources that has to Grant
every single one of us standing in a
lawsuit against the government and some
kind of restitution for this I mean they
were attacking our our businesses MH
they were attacking our character and
they were lying
mhm well and especially in this this
business your credibil credibility is
extremely important and for them to say
you're you're a super spread of
misinformation based on what nothing
from Stanford University that's a direct
attack on your livelihood uh but again I
stand by as as important as I think this
report is I think it's good even if we
all kind of knew this was happening
anyways to get the truth out there what
are the consequences that anyone
involved in this faces realistically
what can we expect going
forward well the one of the things I was
thinking is that we no longer have
public colleges and make them all
private and not allowed to take
government money hell yeah that's what
I'm talking about we should stop giving
out loans that makes that's that made
college expensive too all the student
loans it's like oh there's this big
customer that just came to town you can
charge whatever you want also we are Joe
Biden is on the campaign Trail saying
I'm going to forgive student loan debt
um or you could just start giving out
stop giving out student loans right
right this broken system that put
hundreds of millions of Americans into
debt we are just continuing to say we're
going to do even though on the other
hand we're saying we're going to forgive
student loans it doesn't make any sense
if the system is broken stop doing it
how integrated is the student loan what
is it Fanny May Freddy or those the like
a FAFSA application right is that what
it was when you go to college and then
they tell you whether you're eligible or
not and then they give you all the cash
and as long as you're a student you
don't have to start paying it back and
even if you don't pay it back I don't
think they can arrest you for it so
there's a lot of people that go and they
just never make payments it wrecks your
credit but refuse toay back that's
probably why they're just forgiving it
because they know they're not going to
get it any and it doesn't incentivize
colleges to actually do anything to make
College affordable right all the prices
went way up the expectation is that you
take out a student loan a
government-backed loan but it's not that
they accommodate you in any way I mean
that's why it's interesting to see you
know um like University Phoenix are
online programs that are saying like
we're trying to give you an option here
that is Affordable because ultimately
isn't that where Shaq went University of
Phoenix got his Doctorate
sh tons
it's um It's A system that the federal
government ultimately benefits from
because they say we really we you should
go to college college is so important
also take they were smart though they
would only offer it for targeted Fields
they'd be like all right our competitors
is doing this so we need more Engineers
but how do we incentivize people to be
Engineers oh we give them way more or we
only give money to people who are going
to major in this thing or graduate with
this thing and you're only eligible your
interest rate's way higher if you don't
graduate you know and if you graduate it
goes down there's ways you can
manipulate how you give people money to
give get them to do what you want but
they they're just blanketing it well we
know there are workers shortages in
certain Fields right it's not an
immediate solution they have to go
through training it'll be four five year
delay on the other hand you would get
qualified people going into the there
are enough students entering College who
say I don't really know what I want to
do that if you said but I'll give you a
scholarship I'm going to loan you money
for a business you don't know you want
to start yet do make any sense if if I
was saying oh there's a nursing stor
right or there's um I don't I don't know
what is specific types someone who works
with you know elderly people and I said
you know you go to college right Boomers
get real old uh if you go to college for
this thing I will give you the money for
it you have to graduate with this degree
and go into that field that would make
way more sense to me than the government
saying no worries you may literature you
got it yeah and I did get a degree in
now I'm just kidding uh that's the thing
it doesn't it doesn't make sense uh and
ultimately I don't understand why the
federal government logically would be
supporting this unless they know
ultimately they're able to pull strings
and have universities back sort of
Nefarious schemes that they have they
have uh contrived to pull off against
the American people
if I had not been able to get a loan for
theater or for whatever General I did
like Communications and journalism and
then theater but I could have got a loan
for like a math degree I would have got
a math degree cuz I didn't have the
money I couldn't have gone to college
without a loan or what if they didn't
give you a loan for anything and you
just went and got a job you might
working I just started doing theater
local theater went up to Cleveland done
theater in Cleveland that's kind of what
I was doing anyway part of my day would
be that 30 seconds between the car and
your front
door Goodwill Hunting when I knock and
you're not there
you should be you shouldn't be a
construction worker you should be doing
exactly what you're doing thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net